cute little bugger innit kind of like a
kangaroo mixed with a bunny only without
those obnoxious oversized ears you're
trying too hard rabbit anyway this is
the agouti and well I hate to endanger
its charm I have to let you know it's a
rodent and a big one at that growing up
to two pounds and two feet long but hear
me out
not all rodents hang out in sewers and
train bands of misfit Turtles the agouti
prefers the rain forests of Central and
South America where it browses on fruits
and nuts in fact it's one of the only
critters in the forest that can crack
the notoriously tough Brazil nut and
that means it's nearly free of
competition problem is Brazil nuts can
weigh 3 pounds and fall from 100 feet
high that's pretty much a missile so
flat no goo T's are not uncommon in the
rain forest the critter won't always eat
nuts right away sometimes it buries them
like a squirrel would and that's a huge
help for the Brazil nut tree in such a
dense forest it can't spread its seeds
around on its own so truck on little
feller and watch for falling nuts